[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا احنا هيك وصلنا
الى احلى فقره على ما يبدو في برنامج
الصباح
مائده منوعه من اطعمه الفطور الطازجه
يستيقظ العراقيون كل صباح عليها الفطور او
الريوق باللهجه المحليه وجبه اساسيه
بالنسبه الى العراقيين ما يجعل الفطور
العراقي مميزه عن نظيره في الدول العربيه
والعالميه ايضا بكثره الاكلات الشعبيه
المشبعه بدهم يعرف العراقيون او يعرف عددا
من الاكلات الشعبيه مثل
ما اظن لازم انت بتعرف مقلمه
بالدهن كباب باكر معلاق قيمر وكاهي هذه
كلها اكلات لن تجدوها الا
المطبخ العراق يا قلبي
يلا خلينا نبلش اذا معنا مشاهدينا في
الاستوديو زيد نازو صاحب مطعم تما ومرق
العراق والشيف
رمزي اهلا وسهلا فيكم معنا اول شيء تمن
ومرق هذا اسم المطبخ كم سعره حرام طبعا
الملاحظ بانه بالفعل المطبخ العراقي
بيعتمد يعني جرعه هائله من الدهون على
الريوق على الفطور
شعب عامل فاذا ما نطلع من الصبح نضرب
الريوق الزين ما راح نقدر نكمل يومنا اللي
هو ينتهي يوم بالاربعه بالخمسه على
اجوائنا فنضطر يعني ضروري جدا خلينا نفوت
دايركت بالشيخ مصطفى باقي الدهن طبقه
المفضله انا بس خلينا نقول للناس شنو
الحجم الكبير طبعا مسلوقه والخبز يتشرب
بيها واحنا نقول شوي للناس تفضل عليها دهن
ودهن الحر او الزيت
وعليها بيض مقليه هذا اذا معناته خبز تنور
خبز تنور الفول او
الباكلو عليها دهن حر او سم بلدي والبيض
المقلي وهذا الطبق يعني شايفه انا فوائد
لحمه الراس ممبار
تشوف شنو
تختلف الباشا من مكان لمكان القائمه
الموصل
مصلاويه يعني طبعا حسب المناطق كل منطقه
بالعراق يسووها بطريقه مختلفه شويه هاي
المصلاويه اعزل للسام بعد شوي
احمر
كل شيء ناكل الصبح وطبعا
في هاي البصر
هي تختلف نهائي عن اي باسطر ممكن تاكلها
بغير مكان شلون بالبهارات مالتها وبطريقه
الحفظ مالتها فتختلف نهائي حتى طعمها
يختلف يعني هلا راح نجرب طبعا ونعرف قبل
ما ينتهي وقتنا معنا 30 ثانيه
احنا راح نترك المشاهدين ونودعهم علشان
راح هلا نغوص في هاي الطاوله الى اللقاء
شكرا زيد يعطيكم العافيه
مشاهدينا لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات